South Africa struggled to deal with its
racist past may hold some important
lessons for the United States less than
30 years ago the country had one of the
harshest systems of legalized racism in
the world Debora patta reports from
Johannesburg on how the nation faced the
trauma of its history and continues to
deal with it today
this is Constitution Hill it used to be
a prison where former President Nelson
Mandela was held during his treason
trial he believed that no one was born
hating another person because of the
color of their skin
and despite 27 years behind bars
he forgave his jailers and tried to
reconcile a country after decades of
brutality
this is what state sanctioned police
killings looked like under South
Africa's racist regime known as the
Trojan horse massacre
white police men hidden side wooden
crates and opened fire on unarmed
protesters killing three of them
the youngest an 11 year old boy the
incident was captured by CBS News in an
age before cell phone cameras
this type of brutality was rarely caught
on film which is why over three decades
later the police killing of George Floyd
still takes an emotional toll on black
South Africans who find themselves
reliving the trauma of apartheid which
legalized systematic and violent racism
that system was eventually dismantled in
1994 through a negotiated settlement
under former President Nelson Mandela
the country began a process of
truth-telling
in a bid to heal the wounds of its
racist past for seven years the truce
and Reconciliation Commission was
broadcast regularly on national
television led by Nobel Peace Laureate
Archbishop Desmond Tutu who spoke to 60
Minutes Bob Simon it's not easy to to
open wounds it's very painful but if if
you don't want them to fester you must
open them and cleanse them perpetrators
like dirt qudsiya the leader of a
state-sponsored death squad were given
amnesty in exchange for the truth he
told 60 minutes how they routinely
murdered black activists you guys were
playing God we we were God the survivors
of these unspeakable atrocities were
promised
reparations then they went about cutting
his fingers off more than 21,000 victims
testified even tutu broke down and wept
former anti-apartheid campaigner
Reverend Frank Chu Connie nearly died
after being poisoned by the apartheid
government he forgave his perpetrator
bitterness destroys you it doesn't
destroy the person who cost you the pain
but he has not forgotten forgiving
doesn't mean forgetting the guy who
taught her to be still the guy who
tortured me it doesn't change but my
attitude against him becomes completely
different the process was flawed many
victims felt cheated out of justice but
it did open up a national dialogue in
which white South Africans could no
longer deny the crimes committed in
their name and 26 years later race
remains the enduring fault line of this
country's discourse we have more
conversations around race races a
conversation that never ends in our
country pata Mady Libya believes South
Africans are better at talking about
race than Americans
but reconciliation is hard if like him
you live in a Township where some
residents still don't have electricity
how do you forgive if you're still
hungry
there's still this thing that stands
before me this blackness that hinders me
and everything I do how do I then even
as a new generation say we forgave some
South Africans believe the US would
benefit from a similar truth-telling
process and everybody agreed there's no
quick fix you have to keep on having
uncomfortable conversations but words
must be accompanied by economic justice
yeah that's right Debora patta in
Johannesburg South Africa for us with an
important report there on confronting
the past if you ever want to cleanse the
wounds of that past thank you very much